vanessa hutchins recreating a scene from
high school musical 2 on tick-tock
alongside hoda copy and jenna bush hagar
[Music]
the clip was posted to today with hoda
and jenna's tick tock account
what about everything we've been
[Music]
of course the original scene features
vanessa alongside zac efron
[Music]
but vanessa hoda and jenna totally did
it justice
[Music]
2021 marks the 15-year anniversary of
the first high school musical movie and
vanessa reflected on the milestone with
e.t earlier this month
it's so weird to me that it's that long
ago because
i feel like when i go to work and when i
especially get to do a musical i still
feel the same excitement and and joy
and passion for it i feel like my job it
turns me into a big kid or i get to be a
big kid because i'm playing pretend the
child like wonder of it all it never
dies and i'm i'm still so humbled and so
grateful
for
all the opportunities and all the
adventures i've had
[Music]
vanessa does have a ton of opportunities
these days she voices a character in the
new animated netflix flick my little
pony a new generation and out later this
year netflix's musical adaptation of
tick tick boom co-starring andrew
garfield and directed by lin manuel
miranda tick tick boom have you gotten a
chance to see a cut of it yet i have not
seen a cut i have been told um that the
director's cut is one of the best
director cuts people have seen
um which is very exciting i wouldn't
expect anything less from lin-manuel
miranda yeah so it's really exciting but
he'll he'll send me random text messages
every now and then and it always just
like makes me feel like my heart race
and i'm like oh my god he's so sweet and
he'll like send me a random screen grab
of me where he's like editing and it's
just me pulling faces because that's
apparently something that i do
quite often
did it make you want to revisit solo
music um
you know i feel like i'm singing on my
own all the time my passion and my main
priority has always been acting i think
that like if the right moment came along
with the right people where i felt
really inspired and it happened in a way
that felt organic i would of course be
down to do it um
but till then you know i'm not trying to
put anything into a box that doesn't fit
or or rush anything
you